hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast emerging trends in heart
failure therapy and the importance of
natural Redick peptides I am Brenda
Kelly Jim labyrinth and I'll be your
moderator for today dear event we have
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by roche diagnostics broached
is a leader and research-based focus
healthcare with combined strengths and
pharmaceuticals and diagnostics they are
the world's largest biotech company with
truly differentiated medicine in
oncology virology inflammation
metabolism and CNS Roche is also the
world leader in in vitro diagnostics
tissue-based cancer diagnostics and a
pioneer and diabetes management for more
information please visit cardiac roach
calm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit your
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many of your questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation properly
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window and submit your problem through
the green Q&A button lower left I would
now like to introduce today's speakers
dr. Rob Fitzgerald our speaker today is
from the University of California San
Diego dr. Fitzgerald received his BS
degree in chemistry at Loyola College of
Maryland and his doctorate in
pharmacology toxicology at the Medical
College of Virginia Virginia
Commonwealth University after two and a
half years as a forensic toxicologists
for the state of Virginia he took
position as the director of mass
spectrometry laboratory at the San Diego
VA hospital where he worked from 1992
until 2011
currently Rob is a professor in the
department of pathology at the
University of California San Diego where
he is the director of the toxicology
laboratory an associate director of the
clinical chemistry lab he is board
certified in toxicology and clinical
chemistry by the American Board of
clinical chemistry Rob's teaching
responsibilities include acting as the
course chairman from laboratory medicine
and serving as the director of the
pathology residency clinical chemistry
program and as the director become a AC
accredited clinical chemistry fellowship
I will now turn it over to dr.
Fitzgerald presentation thanks Brendan
for the introduction and it's a pleasure
to be here today to talk about nanotech
peptides my talk is primarily going to
focus on nt-probnp but I'm also going to
show some data on DNT and and how they
compare and really the the point of my
talk is that both of the neck Reddick
peptides dnp and nt-probnp are
critically useful but there are a few
differences that you should be aware of
and we'll go through that momentarily so
as far as a conflicts of interest and
background I do get paid an honorarium I
have had research support from roche as
well as a variety of other clinical
diagnostic manufacturers so just as a
bit of a background and review so that
we're all sort of on the same page I
indicated at nt-probnp which is the
molecule targeted by the Roche assay and
BNP which is a molecule targeted by a
variety of other clinical diagnostic
assays have a lot of similarities and
that sort of makes sense because they
start from the same pro molecule so
pro-bnp is 108 amino acids long another
take home message is that these are
markers of stretch so myocyte stretch in
the case of volume overload in heart
failure myocytes are stretched and they
sense that and release both BNP and NT
pro there's an enzyme called Corrin
which cleaves the pro molecule into an
inactive fragment that's empty pro-bnp
we say amino terminus or nt-probnp the
first 76 amino acids and BMP which is
the active form own 32 amino acids with
that cysteine connected ring so that
that that ring structure on BNP is is
also common in A&P and CNP to other
kinds of natick peptides natura this
means excretion of sodium so along with
sodium goes water and you volume deplete
it also has direct Baeza dilating effect
so it is a hormone that's that's trying
to counteract the D compensation
mechanisms that are oftentimes really
related so another another important
point about DMT is is we'll talk about
in the next slide so just sort of a
summary between the 2 i've talked about
the difference in the amino acids half
place is clearly a difference between
these two so BNP has a half-life of
about 20 minutes and nt-probnp has a
significantly longer half-life so acute
changes might be reflected better by BNP
NT pro having a longer half-life might
be more sensitive in some screening
cases another significant difference is
stability so BNP is unstable at room
temperature and whereas NT pro is
clearly more stable and we'll look at
that in a couple of other slides an
important difference is the range and
this is confusing for clinicians if
you're switching because the range for
BNP typically goes up to about 5,000
where the range of nt-probnp can go to
35,000 so they are log distributed and
that can cause some confusion finally
the clearance different mechanisms dnp
is cleared by variety
Systems one is an enzyme called nephro
licen and that's going to come up at the
end of the talk because there's a new
drug that actually targets that in the
the mechanism of action there is to
increase the NT level to stave off
effects of decompensation so we're going
to come back to that but net roll icing
works on BMP to degrade it whereas
nt-probnp is not affected by that so
this is a so the beginning of my talk is
going to be more focused on the
laboratory side because of important
laboratory differences that the
laboratory and should know and then
we're going to go into some of the
clinical utility of these two markers in
different clinical settings because I
think it's important to understand that
boat from a laboratory and as well as a
comment clinical view so at the top
we're looking at so the y-axis we're
looking at percent of original value on
the x-axis we're looking at time in
hours and so in the orange line it's
pretty much straight across it 100
percent that's showing nt-probnp is
stable over 48 hours whereas at room
temperature if a sample sits around for
four hours you get about a thirty
percent decrease in bmt and if it sits
around longer than that it can be up to
50 or more so so BNP clearly in vitro is
unstable at room temperature so very
similar slide looking at refrigerated
again NT pro is stable whereas BNP
although it's stable for the four state
first eight hours after about 24 hours
you start to see significant decreases
in concentrations of BNP because it's
being decorated and if you look at
frozen same thing BNP is unstable frozen
now we've changed our x-axis two days so
this time in the freezer at minus 20 vs
empty pro is is quite stable frozen so a
clear difference between these molecules
this B&B is more unstable than T pro a
pre-analytical variable that you need to
think about
there's a there's also a fair amount of
hype or myths or whatever you want to
call it that people say that BNP works
better in renal failure than nt-probnp
and this slide is a good example
comparing both BNP and nt-probnp in the
setting of renal failure so on the y
axis we have concentrations of either
BNP or NT pro on the x axis we have GF
are so decreasing GFR or increasing GFR
so as you move to the right on the x
axis these are more healthy and so you
can say if you move from right to left
so we're moving in this direction you
can see that dnp goes up as you get
increase or decrease in renal failure
and the same thing can be seen here as
your NT pro now we're looking at st.
patients analyzed by your vm t or
nt-probnp so interestingly as s GFR goes
down both of the natriuretic peptides go
up and clearly this is at higher
concentrations on the mt pro side and
again that has a bigger dynamic range
and so that's something to remember
what's also super important about this
slide is if you look at this data so
these are patients with or without heart
failure so looking at the y axis we're
looking at the with or without heart
failure and you can see that patients
with low GFR that don't have heart
failure have very low concentrations of
NT pro and so clearly the increases of
NT pro in the setting of renal failure
have meaning so in the absence of renal
failure you don't get the same increases
of NT pro in the setting of chronic
kidney disease another another myth or
whatever you want to call it about the
differences between DNT and NT pro is
that dnp has one cut off and that's not
enough it does have one call off
Pro has age-adjusted cut offs and the
myth is that concentrations of BNP do
not change with age and so this is data
taking from a variety of sources showing
that BMP concentrations on the y-axis
versus age on the x-axis you can clearly
see that as age goes up so does dnp in a
very similar manner if you look at mt
pro it's almost the same kind of a slope
with age NT Prokos up however only NT
Pro was approved at an age adjusted call
and so well it might be easier to use a
single cut off it seems like there is
value in adjusting for age it is clearly
and it has an effect of both Natura dick
sometimes so analytically some key
points NT pro is more stable that's
that's that's a fact the precision of
both NT pro and BNP on automated assays
are quite good so they fulfil you know
the ability to monitor with in
biological change of patients NT pro has
a bigger range from five to thirty five
thousand verses bmt has a more narrow
range and so if you're if your
clinicians are switching from one test
to the other that can cause issues
because they're used to seeing things at
lower concentrations and these are log
distributed so that that is a challenge
and that's real but they both they both
have similar utility and we're going to
look at that shortly so what about the
biological variability the biological
variability of NT pro is about
twenty-five percent and probably similar
to be empty maybe a little bit less
clearly age does have an effect on both
natural except eyes DNT and NT pro women
also have and has an effect as well as a
as a body mass index so there are a
variety of variables that affect both
both b + P&H
Oh bmv that clinicians should be aware
of so how is it a how how is it approved
to be used and what to the the major
guidelines say in 23 2013 the American
College of Cardiology foundation
American Heart Association so these are
the leaders leading cardiologist how do
you use a natural except tides and so a
variety of way to do that there are
proofs of class one level of evidence a
so the highest level is the utility and
diagnosis of heart failure also has a
class 1a for prognostic evaluation of
heart failure and Klaatu for achieving
guideline assisted and guidance for
decompensation therapy so switching
gears a little bit from the analytical
we're going to talk about some of the
clinical utility of the natick peptides
and starting out with primarily what
they were designed to do and then moving
into you know we have really surpassed
the vision for metric peptides initially
that they could just be used for
diagnosis and clearly they have some
other things and we'll talk about that
so next couple of slides going to be on
diagnosis in a cute symptoms of heart
failure so study is similar to the the
breeding not proper trial it was were
done for bmt this was a looking at ed
patients coming in and they asked
clinicians to to estimate the likelihood
for heart failure either low so zero
percent or they were pretty certain they
had heart failure a hundred percent and
then they were blinded to the NT pro
result so really this was how good heart
failure is a clinical diagnosis and so
clearly I think no one is trying to say
that the natick peptide should should
replace a good clinical exam and so
physicians were able
to do their their routine clinical
assessment and what you can see from
this slide is that thirty one percent of
the subjects they were uncertain of the
diagnosis of heart failure so if it was
if they were twenty percent saying
unlikely they were saying that they were
classified as certainly as not having
heart failure if they're eighty percent
or above they said that that was in a
certainty of having heart failure so
thirty one percent of the subjects were
in the gray zone or the uncertain zone
and what's interesting about that is is
that if you look at those patients the
net Reddick peptide was actually better
than clinical diagnosis as far as a
receiver operator characteristic kerman
and we'll look at that day in a second
but of that thirty one percent fifty
percent had heart failure so a large
amount half of the heart failure
patients were in that group so you say
okay well what happens with those
uncertainties and so they track that and
this is a hazard plot so hazards fill up
on the y-axis versus dates and
presentation and you can see in the sort
of orange plot the patients that were in
the gray or the indecisive area had a
significantly higher hazard ratio so
there were bad implications of not
getting the diagnosis correct what that
slide is really sore 20 so a lot of
people are concerned if they're
switching from bmp-2 NT pro how do they
how do they compare head-to-head and so
this was a acute dips Nia so acute
shortness of breath looking at mt pro
concentration versus on the y-axis
versus bmv concentrations on the x-axis
you see if there's a very rough
correlation you know if you had a
shotgun you can sort of sweep it in that
area but as DNT goes up so does NT pro
and that's been our experience as well
so probably a better example that is is
looking at this slide so 251 patients
that presented with shortness of breath
they gotta be
a as well as an NT pro and we're looking
at a receiver operator characteristic
curve so if the tests are as good as
flipping a coin it would be along that
dotted purple line and you can compare
test by looking at area under the curve
so basically we're talking about on the
bottom right area under the curve and
you see that the blue line and the
orange line orange line being anti Pro
blue line being dnp pretty much overlay
each other so they have the same
diagnostic efficiency for acutely
decompensated heart safe so both
nt-probnp work pretty well so let's
again look at the the clinical judgment
versus NT Pro and so this is data where
a Canadian study where clinicians were
again either randomized to getting a BMP
or not getting a BMP and we're looking
at receiver operator characteristic
curves so the Green Line is clinical
judgment so that's without a net Reddick
peptide measurement and you can see that
it has an area under the curve of about
point 8 3 whereas NT probe by itself
without any other clinical acumen you
know medical school etc a biomarker by
itself had an area under the curve that
was actually higher than clinical
judgment so pretty pretty much
equivalent 86 however and the intended
use of these products are shown by the
orange line where the highest area under
the curve if you add NT Pro and clinical
judgment and you compare that to
clinical judgment alone the p-value is
is quite significant so it's quite clear
that that empty Pro adds the clinical
judgment and the this study was was
really interesting because not only did
it add the clinical judgment but they
actually followed patients to see how
they did so they looked at both the
clinical and the economic impact so
the the reference if you want to look at
up 500 patients that presented with
shortness of breath at seven different
emergency departments in Canada and
basically they got randomized to either
getting an empty pro or being blinded to
an empty Pro result 200 and that 500
patients 230 of them had heart failure
and the median concentration of NT pro
and that patient cohort was about 30
3700 picograms per mil whereas the
median in the patients without heart
failure was 200 so quite clearly p some
huge p-value differentiates us too so
clearly NT pro can differentiate heart
failure from not having heart failure
but the power of this study is shown in
the next slide not only did it identify
patients but patients that had were in
the NT pro arm reduced admission
duration by twenty one percent their
Hospital rehospitalization was decreased
by thirty five percent and that sort of
makes sense that if you if you are that
much more efficient with getting your
patients triage appropriately you reduce
overall direct medical costs and you
take better care of your patients so a
really powerful biomarker study that
shows not only that it works to diagnose
but it can actually improve outcomes
both from a clinical as well as a
financial perspective so sort of a huge
win for biomarkers so in summary NT pro
in heart failure evaluation general
concepts a lot of similarities with DNT
there they're both stretch markers so
they go up in other things besides heart
failure but they generally have the same
same strengths and weaknesses so
differential diagnosis it is important
to remember these are stretch markers
there are other things that can call
stretch and that they portend bad
outcomes which is
prognosis and what we're going to talk
about in a variety of different clinical
settings so here look we'll look at a
prognosis in acute symptomatic patients
so it's a huge body of evidence that
shows that both natural except tides are
associated with severity of disease so
increasing heart failure severity you
get increases in the natural peptides
there are other comorbidities that you
can use to predict outcomes but NT pro
is independently prognostic of those
other such as ejection fraction age
other other comorbid conditions and so
as we as I pointed out before is that
natural peptides of our prognostic in
other states besides heart failure so
whether just talk for another causes
elevations so how often do you measure
NT pros this is a study looking at post
treatment values and how patients did so
a survival plot again so the oranges
plot is where natura dick peptides in
the hospital actually increased by
thirty percent and so those patients did
far worse in two hundred days they were
they had a survivability it was less
than than twenty percent or actually I
started cumulative rehospitalization
whereas if in the hospital they
decreased but if they're in t probe
decreased by more than thirty percent
they did clearly did better and if they
had a change that was less than thirty
percent clearly significantly different
than patients who who had big increases
while in the hospital so some changes of
NT pro and BNP are important so acute
shortness of breath patients any
elevations of the natural except I'd
seem to have prognostic value so at
presentation
NT Pro is important and then monitoring
them typically after treatment and what
clinicians are trying to do there you'll
hear a term called a wet BNP versus a
dry BNT a wet BNP is a dmt in the
setting of decompensation and so in that
setting that BNP is going to be high
because the patients are decompensated
and the natick peptides are trying to
overcome the effects of the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
having a dry B&T is important because
and that's hopefully going to be after
treatment after treatment after the
patient's and stabilize they've you know
gotten rid of the extra fluids you want
to know a dry be empty because that's
really what's going to be monitored in
an outpatient clinic and what clinicians
are going to be interested in
determining if it's if they're dry BNP
is changing so by getting cereal
measurements you can get both a wet and
a dry BMP and obviously as I said before
these are used in the context of
clinical care so there are other
clinical variables that clearly are
important so we will switch gears a
little bit and talk about prognosis and
chronic heart failure so chronic heart
failure is difficult there's a variety
of models that have been developed based
on age X infractions renal function etc
but if you look at the the prognostic
utility of nt-probnp and BNP they're
actually quite powerful in the setting
of chronic heart failure and they are
independent if you if you do statistical
analysis two other major comorbidities
so here's a study looking at 5,000
patients with chronic heart failure and
looking at if I waiting risk of
mortality or hospitalization Park
failure what this study showed is that
nitric peptides are
x value it's not just a plus or minus
marker so the degree of elevation has
importance and even the degree of
elevation below the cutoff values for
diagnosis and so we'll look at that so
here is a cumulative probability of
mortality were NT pro based on quartiles
so patients were highest quartile mid
quartiles and lowest and so you can see
that less than 370 for the cumulative
probability of mortality was low as you
go up in court owls you get increased
probabilities of dying very similarity
similar plot just looking at
rehospitalization again the same
quartiles hold true whereas these are
these are anti pro if you look at how
does be a p working and a lot of people
are concerned about the comparisons of B
and D and NT pro so both of these are
the cumulative probabilities show
increased probability of mortality as
you go up in court owls what's
interesting about this is that the cough
for BNP is a hundred and even below the
cutoff there's importance in the
concentration so across the continuum of
concentrations both NT pro and DNT have
meaning so final plots just showing the
same thing for hospitalizations for BNP
so time in guns forces probability
versus the quartiles of being the
highest quartile has the highest
probability for either mortality or hop
rehospitalization so in the in the
setting of chronic heart failure and
these patients are seen in the
outpatient clinic and doing serial
samples what does that tell you about
either mortality or hospitalization so
if you start out
NT Pro concentrations on the y-axis
versus time in months so this is a four
month time span if patients are low to
start with and four months later they're
still low they have a mortality of about
nine percent and hospitalizations of
about seven percent so low however if
you look at patients that start high so
there was a thousand patients in
thirteen hundred patients in this disarm
of the study four months later they were
still high they had two and a half times
the mortality rates of about twenty five
percent mortality and about twenty-seven
percent rehospitalization so high
staying high is bad really actually more
interesting is what happens if they
start out high and they end up low they
start out high and they get on effective
therapy and they're in there NT pro goes
low have about a fourteen percent
mortality and conversely if they start
out low so this is a hundred eighty
patients started out low and went high
and they had a intermediate mortality so
clearly on that serial sampling is a
signal that something bad either
mortality or rehospitalization is a
fairly high probability so points about
NT pro in chronic heart failure they're
strong independent risk predictors so
they're independent of the other things
that have clinical significance they're
useful across the entire spectrum of
severity so from both stage one disease
states for disease they clearly have
affect their additive if you consider
other patient variables such as renal
function and so a couple of slides about
are the natural a peptide is useful in
acs so acute coronary syndrome we
typically think of troponin and the
major difference between sure ponens and
naturally except tides are troponin czar
necrosis markers troponin czar saying
myocytes are dying whereas natura dick
peptides or stretch markers they're
saying my effects are being volume
overloaded and stretched so typically
we're measuring troponin to identify
myocardial infarction but what is the
role of nitric peptides in acute
coronary syndrome so this is a study
looking at separating natick peptides
own admission so on the left side we're
looking at all right we are looking at
NT pro concentration so admission
concentrations of less than 250 vs. on
the right side we're looking at higher
so they're coming in at high so that's
the difference between those two and
what we're going to look at is I what
happens three days later so while
they're in the hospital for an admission
for suspected heart attack three days
later what happened so the Green Line
oops so the green line is they started
out low they had a low NT pro coming in
less than 250 but three days later when
the hospital there there BNP was was
elevated and you see that their outcome
their probability of death or mi was
about eighteen percent so what's
interesting is if you take the patient
population same patient population so
these were patients that came in low and
they stayed low their cumulative
probability of that outcome was quite
low so that changed while in the
hospital has a big impact and in fact if
you look at you look at this sorry we
used to using a pointer so these arrows
a little bit funny if you look at that
green line versus that green line this
really shows the power
or of multiple measurements so own
admission and then at discharge both of
these you know coming in these patients
look very different their baseline NT
pro on the left was low they're based on
mt pro and the right was high yet three
days later they both were on the high
end and they both had bad outcomes of
similar probabilities whereas if they
regard us as if they came in low or if
they came in high this patient group
came in high but they went low and they
had a low outcome so a good prognosis so
while in the setting of acs we're
looking for necrosis with the CH
opponent the mt the amino-terminal of
pro-bnp does have does that value as far
as a prognostic Padma rectification so
NT pro in primary care how the primary
care Doc's use natick peptides shortness
of breath dis ting is a common complaint
in primary care and there's a variety of
reasons that you can get that so it is
an important diagnostic dilemma ideally
you want to have a biomarker that has a
good differential diagnosis helpful has
good sensitivity and specificity has
something that you can actually make
treatment changes on and be
cost-effective so we'll look at a couple
of studies so this is these or two
different studies about 300 patients
each looking at cut-offs for ruling out
heart failure and the optimal cutoff was
a 125 nanograms per liter or picograms
per mil and you see that negative
predictive values were extremely good
and so ruling out heart failure and then
looking at other causes so how do they
how can if you use patients present with
symptoms suggestive of heart failure a
physical exam so as we as I tried to say
before you know cardiologist
are critical to this and in primary care
physicians actually doing a physical
exam because heart failure largely is a
clinical diagnosis that the natura dick
peptides can be so a physical exam ukg
and a natural except I'd measurement if
their natural except I'd is elevated
then they get worked up for having a
possible cardiovascular call if they're
NT pro is low then they they can look
for other symptoms so how can that be
used clinically here's a study that
looked at you know what happens if you
did an echocardiogram on all of the
patients that were suspicious so 367
patients they did echocardiogram Gulf
160 dollars each stomach did that for a
total cost of 58 thousand dollars
however if you use the algorithm that we
suggested where they got an empty Pro is
part of the workup and the only did
echoes on elevated NT pros you only you
ruled out 150 for that 367 so you only
have to do 213 echoes for about thirty
four thousand dollars so total savings
error is going to be about ten thousand
dollars on that 367 patient cohort and
you're avoiding doing echoes on 154
patients so it includes the cost of
doing an attic peptide so so does that
some cost-benefit analysis so
interpreting heart failure in the
setting of chronic disease that goes
back to what we talked about before the
wet and dry so we pointed this out
before a dr ENT is concentration of
natick peptide when the patient is
stable and that's when they come back
into the ED if they have a change in
their dry BNT so
Oh presented the ed was short and
suppressed they don't really know what
the cause is if in their chart they have
a documented NT pro in the setting of a
stable disease they look for a change of
about twenty five percent so a twenty
five percent change as the biological
variability twenty five percent change
from the from the dry suggests that the
patient has changed clinically and needs
optimization and as we've said before
that dry BNP is prognostic so the last
couple of slides them to spend on our
brand new it has to do with a new
therapy for heart disease the drug is
called entrust oh and the reason that
we're going to talk about is because it
does have an effect on on natura dick
peptides so prior to doing that let's
just talk a little bit about this drug
so you it has two different components
so soak you [ __ ] real and valsartan are
the two components so you tsukuba trill
sorry I'm definitely used to using a
pointer versus in Harrow I apologize for
that to coupa drill is a Nepra licen
inhibitor so from the beginning of the
talk we we talked about how BNP gets
degraded Nepra licen is the enzyme that
breaks down vnp into inactive fragments
and so if you inhibit nepra licen which
is what this drug does you get higher
concentrations of BNP and that's good
because BNP has a diuretic effect it
also has data dilating effects so all
things that are going to counteract
what's happening in decompensation and
the end result of decompensation one of
the end result is that you get increases
of aldosterone that goes to the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
valsartan is a is part of this drug so
it's a combination
of the net for lights and inhibitor to
increase DNT an angiotensin 2 receptor
blocker which is going to inhibit the
ability to form aldosterone and some of
the angiotensin one things are gonna
call increases in blood pressure so
combination of these two different drugs
is sort of a novel mechanism and it got
compared with a a very large clinical
trial about 10,000 patients that will
look at that data in a second so so self
sergeant is a drug by itself an
angiotensin receptor blocker it was
already approved but this new
combination with an m4 licen inhibitor
adds a different mechanism of action
that's additive in overcoming the D
compensation mechanisms so just to look
at it again how is it working the drug
has two components the cebu Petrille and
valsartan angiotensin receptor so if you
you if you block this side you decrease
the basic constriction you decrease the
sodium retention and some of the
remodeling effects so an established
drug what's novel about it is on this
side the the neckroll Ison inhibits the
breakdown of BNP so B and D
concentrations are going to go up in the
presence of this drug and VAP as we know
is a direct vasodilator it causes
naturist if you have natural reaches you
get a diuresis it also has some sexual
or fibrosis so this is the the data and
this drug got approved this summer it
actually got stopped early because of
the positive effect so this is showing
about 8,000 patients more than 8,000
patients and the
was compared to an existing therapy so
enalapril is an angiotensin-converting
enzyme inhibitor so a standard of care
in heart failure therapy and this is the
end trust oh and we're only what we're
looking at is really cumulative probably
of a bad end point on the y-axis and you
can see that enalapril has a higher
probability and this p-value when you
have this many patients is hugely
significant so if you look at all of the
outcomes of this clinical child very
powerfully for positive outcomes so very
very little very little adverse effects
in this combination so the heart of the
matter is shown in this slide and that
this is why both cardiologists and
laboratory ins are interested so we're
looking at this is the clinical trial
data and what's happening to the natura
dick peptides and so patients that are
on enalapril in the blue you can see
patients on enalapril there there BNP
goes down with therapy however patient's
own interests oh there be and he
actually goes up so and then that's what
you would expect you would expect
they're not there BNP to go up if
they're being treated effectively and
they're recovering from heart failure
then they're empty pro goes down because
the stimulus for endogenous secretion is
decreased so very positive drop in NT
pro own interests though that's not
quite as evident on enalapril so how
does this affect diagnosis and so from a
diagnostic standpoint I think this is
important because if a patient comes in
decompensated one this drug or
suspicions of being decompensated it's
going to be difficult to use BNP to make
that diagnosis because the effect of the
drug is to increase pnp however the same
page
if they're monitored using NT pro there
NT pro should actually be indicative of
their their endogenous heart failure
status because empty pro is not affected
by the drug that's really what that
that's summary slide shows what was a
sort of almost radical about this is the
United Kingdom actually came out with a
statement that says you know this this
drug study was an international study
with about 10,000 patients so a huge
study involving you know international
collaborators um so potentially could
have a big big impact on you know how
many patients eventually get put on it
and you know the the jury's still out on
that but it does seem to be an effective
drug therapy for heart failure a New
Mexico anyhow what they said is that VAP
is not a suitable biomarker for heart
failure in patients treated with
interests oh because the NP is a
substrate and NT pro is not a substrate
therefore is a more suitable biomarker
we haven't had any statements similar to
that in the US and and then really i
think you know it's early and we're
going to see you no more data is going
to be coming out so whether one is
better than the other it could be that
that BNP is used to see how effective
the drug is working in NT pro can be
used to monitor endogenous secretion so
there there there a lot still to be
learned on that but potentially from a
diagnostic standpoint important to know
so with that I'll thank you for your
attention and be welcome to taking any
questions thank you rob for that
informative presentation before we get
started on our audience questions and
answers I would like to remind them how
to submit their questions questions can
be submitted by typing them in the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button
the lower left of the presentation lid
will try to answer as many of your
questions as we can and with that we
will get right to our first question
attendee s is there a need to convert to
nt-probnp if I'm using BNP given the
fact that and trust o is not on my
hospital formulary yet so I think it
just does not own a lot of hospitals
formularies currently but I think that
you know laboratory ins need to be out
in front of this because if it is on the
formulary and a lot of patients
eventually get put on it then it will
cause some confusion if you don't know
it you know what occupations on it so
currently do you need to switch I would
say that's premature great thank you our
next question how do you suggest the
change from how do you suggest a change
from BNP to nt-probnp be accomplished
with clinicians who are following
patients in an outpatient setting we
just tried to switch once and got
tremendous negative feedback so we had
to switch back to be envied would you
suggest offering both BNP and nt-probnp
for six months or so I think that's
essential you know I think that that
laboratory ins need to remember that
Doc's see patients every day and they
have relationships with patients and
they you know have been monitoring their
labs so they sort of have a gestalt
about what changes are significant and
to make a blind switch without informing
your clinicians is a bad idea we hear
UCSD we face a very similar challenge in
fact the original BNP trials that show
that BNP was a good biomarker we're done
here UCSD at the VA that's associated
and so all of our clinicians from
our residents to our fellows to our
faculty has sort of you know been
brought up in the world of BNP so the
change for us was probably harder than
most places because because of the you
know the history of the biomarkers and
so in our setting we actually did a
six-month comparison where we gave both
values and and in fact you know the data
show that both of them agree quite well
we can show some slides if you think
that that's warranted but took so
clearly it's at least a six month
process you know talk to your laboratory
vendors and see if they can help you out
with cost of doing that because it is an
important change and it should be done
in collaboration for clinicians okay did
you have slides you wanted to show on
that Rob um sure so this is a 500
patients that we did here UCSD and again
the the level of hostility here was was
significant because they were brought up
on BNP and making that switch was was
challenging so looking at 500 patients
and what you can see is that sorry 203
of them were negative by both assays and
278 were positive by both assays so out
of 500 patients we had 10 that did not
agree and if you think about it that's
actually amazingly good and so we sort
of took the view that we would call
these false positives and we would call
these false positives we're really not
making a judgment on which one was right
and we wanted to see what happened to
those patients in time typically in our
hospital if they're concerned about
heart failure decompensation they're
going to order sequential samples
whether in the hospital
so let's look at those 10 patients so
they will recline via the false
positives so here we're looking at a
part of part of what we did was
according to the College of American
Pathologists what you should do is
evaluate reference ranges and so we
looked at reference ranges that were
used in international studies and
actually adopted the icon reference
ranges so what we're looking at here is
the two patients that we called false
positive by BNP so they were positive by
BNP but negative x NT pro and so
important to look at the age group so as
we're looking here less than 50 and 50
to 75 because we have age-adjusted
cut-offs for NT pro so barely positive
by BNP cough being 100 there was not a
second DNT here in our laboratory we use
a cough of 454 for diagnosis on so
negative x NT pro and what happened that
patient this patient was status a heart
surgery and they actually weren't
sufficiently concerned to do a second
natick peptide sample so unclear second
sample that was a false positive DNT
barely positive actually both of these
are really within the error of the
measurement probably of being positive
or negative so just barely positive so
102 900 years are cough in the age group
of 50 to 75 so negative x NT pro only
things in this patient's medical records
they had they were out-of-control
diabetic so again they didn't order a
second natick peptide let's look at the
the last group and this was the what we
called false positive NT pros so again
we have three of the patients were lost
to follow-up so that there was no
follow-up so we couldn't really
determine in an outcome different age
groups less than 50 or 50 to 75 initial
B and P in this facial is 97 NT pro is
950 so so clearly positive this patient
had a bad outcome
but they didn't order a second so we
couldn't really evaluate trends looking
at second patient uh interestingly
negative by BNP own admission so this is
the first value on whereas it was
positive int pro so this put it in a
false positive aunty pro if you look at
what happened the second BNP sample was
posited so sort of confirmed that this
was a you know an elevation and athletic
peptides and the second being NT pro
also was positive so here NT pro was
positive before BNP that will sort of
the outcome patient had a cardiomyopathy
third patient same thing negative on
initial BNP positive on 2nd BN p+
initially and stayed positive on aunty
pro so pulmonary embolus so again there
are other causes for elevations of
nitrate except tides b-sides heart
failure so very similar negative x NT
pro i'm sorry- by BNP goes positive
second sample is positive whereas
initially it was positive for NT probe
and went sky high and so patient had a
diagnosis of heart failure this last one
is probably a kinetic thing so start out
negative and went even more negative for
bmt we talked about the half-life of DMT
being shorter than NT pro nt-probnp
being positive and going negative so
half-life issue patient had a diagnosis
of heart failure so you know sort of
understandable how those labs came to be
so we sort of concluded that a key bro
is more sensitive because it was
becoming positive before BNP and that me
and he was subsequently becoming
positive three to five discrepant asians
so that's sort of a long-winded answer
to a short question so I've got a table
thank you rob our next question how
would you recommend approaching the
topic of interest Oh with clinicians I
think first off you need to find out if
it's
if they're using it or if they plan to
use it so I think one of the things this
is an opportunity for laboratories to
get out of their office so make a
contact in the cardiology department let
them know that you understand that this
new drug is available and you will have
a conversation with them about how your
labs is doing biomarker testing and is
that can impact how they they take care
of patients so a great chance to reach
out and contribute great our next
question moving along are there any
significant known interference with
nt-probnp determinations versus BNP such
as antibiotics hemolysis medications etc
um there are no so so there are I have
to take a closer look at the package
insert my my recollection is that there
are less like we say serum indices
hemolysis enteric like Khemia I think
there are less for anti pro vs DNT but
it's um you know at some level all of
the tests are you know have affected by
serum indices as far as other things
that would be like antibiotics or things
like that I'm not aware of any that
interfere great our next question would
you suggest is the correct serial draw
or collection times for assessment of
nt-probnp so I think that that really
depends on the clinical situation
whether or not they're in the ed or if
they're being monitored in an outpatient
clinic and so in the in the ed I think
our cardiologists really like to have
own admission and close to discharge
again when a mission is going to be the
wet BNP and they want to know what the
dry is for lots of reasons you know one
did they get good care were they able to
you know in the hospital
treatment settings did their BMP drop
and that's going to give them prognostic
information you know how close the
inpatient should be followed how high
either med should be monitored etc
versus in an outpatient setting then I
think it's you know it's going to be
clinician dependent great thank you
another question from one of our
attendees what steps did your facility
take to educate and prepare all
clinicians and lab for switch from BNP
nt-probnp we took a lot of steps because
we knew that it was going to be a major
change and so we actually worked with
Roche to develop a plan started out with
the I reached out to the director of
cardiology and told him what we were
thinking about and really we make
decisions on laboratory platforms based
on our whole healthcare situation we're
not going to make a decision to
implement automation and all the other
things associated with with changing
vendors unless we can take care of all
of the patients we're not taking care of
just cardiology so I think we need to
you know bring that to the table like
now we're trying to improve patient care
for everyone in our hospital that were
responsible for and as part of that
we're going to be switching over and so
started out with you know it's a high
level we had seminars that were I
conducted some of them Roche medical
supports conducted other ones at all
line so on the nursing level on the
laboratory side on Grand Rounds to Corey
ologist and it really sort of what
turned the the table for us was our
cardiologists really didn't want to hear
from a laboratory about how to take care
of their patients and that's
understandable you know they they they
are the front line they interact with
patients you know directly and so we
actually brought in an outside
cardiologist who could give us an
objective
you of the net Redick peptides and that
allowed us to really have a much better
conversation thank you rob that is all
the time that we have for our audience
questions right now I'd like to thank
about the stirrup again for his
presentation and ask him if he has any
final comments for our attendees I
really don't have any final comments i
think that uh these natural peptides
that have made a big change in health
care and in a very positive direction
and so no need to continue to offer that
we need to be aware of changing
therapies and how they can affect
patient care thank you rob we appreciate
your time today bringing this
information to us I would also like to
thank our sponsor roche diagnostics for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
june of 2016 attendees will receive an
email from labyrinth alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay and we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event that's
all we have hope to see you next time
goodbye